hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood
you're about to see a night cycle in the
new place
uh it is currently 1708 which means 508
which means that i still got a good bit
of time
i just got to remember i got to get back
in order to board up
the right places whoa
okay is that going to blow up no it's
not
convenient i don't know if all of the
corpses that look a certain way
blow up good thing i have these
lockpicks oh well this is awfully
convenient to have
immediately adjacent to my house it's
also a little worrisome
uh okay wow i'm full uh
shocking i'll go drop this stuff off the
logs here
ah this stuff back in my house i really
don't know if they're gonna be able to
get in
through there i can barricade it like
last minute but
i don't know if uh that's gonna be the
case there's just enough time it starts
at 20.
i've got time i'm right here i've got
another hour
so let's go get whatever crap we can
find what is that about
oh silo that's right pig shed okay
whoa fire that can't be good
a wolf's camp but he's not here oh he is
here oh my god he's here
hi bud i'll be damned i barely believe
my beautiful eyes
you made it i need to admit you're quite
resourceful piece of meat
the wolf smiles revealing a row of sharp
teeth
time to get to the specifics follow the
path located to the southern edge of the
silent forest you'll get to a village
where you'll find a hag who reeks of
chickens
talk to her maybe you'll learn something
interesting i did
be on your guard comrade don't let her
deceive you with that kind face of hers
the selfish [ __ ] is keeping something
that does not belong to her behind the
locked door of her house
something i'm after bring me the key to
that door and i will tell you where to
find the thing you lost
is it fair comrade a key for a key
good now take off get to work
ah sure looks like no one else will
enlighten you listen
the inhabitants of our lovely village
hold many many secrets
treasures they do not wish to share with
anyone those selfish deceitful wretches
they think they're superior because they
have human gobs they treat us like
lepers
but you know what [ __ ] them we're
buddies aren't we
and them they deserve to be punished
meat
wolf who moves closer to me hear that
squealing
it's one of their secrets the wolf grins
listening to the distant sound with
great relish
find that pig shed meat make that squeal
and stop and the treasure will be yours
okay
photo the doctor well well i know this
quack
a non-entity a third-rate witch doctor
useless [ __ ] clunker
but he still managed to screw you over
with that kia comrade all right cool
do i have any i have like no reputation
with you ah
all right you know i'm gonna get out
here before the night falls
i'm guessing you wouldn't like me going
into your uh
crates but this one's okay okay last one
then i gotta get back
okay a knife that's probably useful
okay gotta get out of here yeah i know i
must return to my audit
i'm well aware okay generator is on
we're gonna button up this place
tighter than you know what and you
know why this is boarded up this is not
boarded up i don't have any
well technically i guess i don't really
need to board those up
uh let me just do whatever i can with
what i have prioritizing
the important things and then going from
there so uh
the most important thing that i need to
board up probably just
for now actually i think just this door
because they can they can come in here
and that's fine
unless uh you know what let's go for the
whole shebang
and i'm gonna save some just in case i
need to board up the door
adjacent to me and just enough time okay
i'm gonna board up this one
the torch went out of course it did i
wasn't paying attention i i
think this door might be okay i also
might want to barricade it anyway
but i'm not 100 sure yeah i'm not i
i just don't know things okay
hello what are you doing over there
better not be messing with my generator
yeah oh hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa
what the hell was that
oh my god
i i'm i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do the
thing i'm gonna do the thing i'm gonna
do the thing
here we go okay you wanna go
huh [ __ ] ow frick okay yeah that's the
only hit you get
this yeah yeah yeah
okay close that there you go
get some wrecked you up
wreck tom no no
no there we go oh my god
oh my god i gotta barricade this
immediately it was so stupid of me to
think that that wouldn't keep him out
oh my god that was so stupid of me to
think that that wouldn't work i almost
died
oh no i need to repair this no god i've
forgotten how
repair item cool that's repaired
i'm so stupid give me your stupid crap
i need another bandage oh i can't make
another bandage i've got
stick as a backup and i've got pills
that's right pills
oh yeah that's okay
man they're really trying to get in this
time
oh crap no what is the float
what is that what is that supposed to be
why are the savages not affected by the
oh you do
no oh i will mess you up buddy
i will mess you the frick up
oh frick that's what you don't get
missed me
[ __ ] missed me
[ __ ]
got him dead oh crap but i don't have
enough wood to barricade this
craw crap oh my god that's terrible
oh no that's not good i don't have wood
i gotta cuddle all those logs tomorrow
all of you are dead and i'm alive
that's what makes the big difference
between you and me
i'm a survivor i don't know how they do
it every single night is so
tense i thought that you know the night
is long
hi hey bud welcome in
uh make yourself at home the man stands
before him emotionless
suddenly he starts to move quicker as if
looking for something in his pockets
he takes out a piece of charcoal and
starts writing on his palm
there's no way out of here brother he
shows me what he's written then wipes it
with his sleeve and continues scribbling
we're stuck with each other after making
sure i've also read the second sentence
the man takes out a full tan
of gasoline from his sack places it on
the floor next to me
well thank you this guy's so nice that
goes oh
so nice to me no you're such a
sweetheart
i probably have some stuff to give to
you wait someone's attached a note to
this bell
liquor tasting and transport services
fast and efficient call now
huh something is happening what is
happening
anyway i can make a lantern that's nice
oh what the hell
ho hello hello
bye oh hey there boss i'll be honest
here boss i'm really thirsty you see
i could share a refreshing beverage with
a weary traveler i would make it worth
your while
ash's dashes dusted us when life's a
[ __ ]
booze is immersed
a beautiful road mr boss man long and
straight you'll find only twisted paths
in these parts
let me tell you something good looker
straightens out all the pass every
single one of them
okay well i'll i'll i'll be back i don't
have any on me right now
i'll be right there hang on hang on hang
on hold hold your horses
how about two boozes would that help
alcohol ah good vintage a bottle a day
keeps
monsters away do your health boss if you
want boss i can bring your junk from the
other hideout
[Music]
yeah yes which hideout should it from
the draw oh my god
i wanted like a nun and a cucumber field
boss oh my god thank you
what the hell that's so confu thank you
that's son yes oh my god
okay anyway uh i gotta get these shiny
stones
to the dude fan belt is of no value i'm
assuming this is all to some kind of a
vehicle that i'm gonna be able to put
together
i'm not gonna sell too much stuff to him
i'm gonna make this lantern though
yes excellent i don't know if i can just
fill that up with gas that would be
great if i could
let's give him the shiny stone
oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
and i can get the fabric which i
shouldn't have given to him in the first
place i'm just taking this back that's a
big punishment to my
reputation but all right and with that i
can craft something
boom two more pieces that'll be
fantastic that'll be great
uh and actually i'm going to take this
gas and i'm gonna chop
up the goodies i'll take two just in
case
okay we've got tons of wood good
good wood we used up uh two cans of
gasoline but frankly
i'm not too disappointed about that
that's actually okay in my book
um the lantern oh the lantern just goes
oh interesting well i don't need it for
now i suppose that
it only burns fuel when it's on my hot
bar because that's the only time it's
illuminating
all right mr man it's been good seeing
you
i got a lot of splorn to do there's
apparently a pig pen and apparently i
got to talk to the chicken lady again
which is not something i'm looking
forward to
but it's something that's got to be done
i'm going to take one of these just in
case
i guess i'm going to go now
you know what actually this rain is um
really making it kind of dark
that's actually not that much better
oh hello what the hell oh is this the
silo
hello hi
uh oh mannequin i
[Music]
know
whoa i hate this
[Applause]
got it nailed it
is there anything in here oh no
oh no oh no someone made this their home
oh good oh great oh good yeah
oh good dead rat great
that's just what you want to see great
place
oh that's a lot of use oh no wait that's
just
to use still that's two that's two more
than i would like to
take on it's just really dark
in these woods really really
dark i wouldn't be able to see any
goodies lying around that
whoa almost wouldn't be able to see that
got it oh hello
oh where was that
oh hello ah this looks like something
i don't know what is this the pig farm
oh some defenses
someone cut the cables they lead to the
pig shed through a hole in the wall but
they've been
cut what do i need to build them
i need wire of course i do oh is that a
bunch of pickheads
by looking smell of these it seems
they've been here for quite some time
oh no
ah a lever i need to turn on the power
to use the lever
okay good that means i need cables to do
that
hello oh get the [ __ ] out of here freak
uh
you know i will but i need to see this
but before i do you want to talk buddy
ah oh oh he warned me oh he did warn me
oh yeah he warned me oh he warned me
yeah he he definitely warned me
it's fine bud all right bud you take
care now bud
there's something going on over there
something
seriously going on over there okay well
i'm guessing this is the
pig farm yeah definitely the i'm here
yep i'm at the pig farm that's for sure
uh what to do with the pig form i have
no idea but i'm gonna go down to piotrex
house
do i know who pierce is i'm kind of bad
with names so i don't know if i've
actually met peo trick yet
i still don't whoa i still don't wha
whoa oh hey okay you know what you know
what
let's do it let's do it
dodged ya missed me come on
miss me got him okay
i'm getting better at that and by that i
mean
but you know i'm getting better at it
have i been here have i been here
did i been here have i been here i might
have been here
yeah no no i have not been here
uh okay oh rope
that is valuable you can have the dead
rats
why is the music all being the way that
it is
hello piotrek pietrick
piatrick patrick a pile of junk sloppily
welded together
okay this is once a tractor now to
hollow rusted body
all of its useful mechanical parts have
been scavenged
oh hey bud
combine those and put it back no one
will ever know i only took a little bit
heavy smell of gasoline in the air junk
i can burn that but i don't have a torch
on me
gasoline uh again er good the alcohol i
know is very valuable now
um so much crap
all right well gas you know i'm okay on
gas i think this will stack with the
other one
yeah okay so i got two of those that's
good uh
pierre trek piatrick
hello this place looks like a scrap
metal warehouse the walls are covered
with fungus and spider webs it's very
stuffy in here
you okay i smell rosin rosin what's
rosin
postcard portrait of a nun nebo just aim
avema
mabeska all right tape
that's probably also useful but i have
no space left hello
locked i need a key who's there hi are
you
i'm not coming out until that beast
lurking in my garage is gone
i'm sorry the garage with the tractor in
it that i was just in
what beast are you talking about you
want to run that by me
two more times i could open it with a
lock pick do i have a lockpick
i don't have any lockpicks well that
answers that question okay so
there's apparently like a dog in there
or something i'm guessing i could take
care of a dog but i'm full up i can't
exactly do anything else
oh i could use the meat as bait i
suppose i need to head back to my base
and i don't know if that's gonna leave
me enough time
to do anything else yeah i need to drop
off this stuff
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh crap oh god
oh god here we go
ah oh my god try me trying to try me
no i messed that up
dodged yes did not mess that up
got him man i gotta stop taking hits
like this
give me the pills odd meat cookable rots
over time you know what i'll take it
oh my god i can't oh god get away from
me i can't take another dog right now
i gotta switch weapons and i have no
idea how this one handles
what is that your lungs are more
efficient oh good that was some pill
that was a good pill huh that was a real
slam and pill
oh my goodness oh
oh all right not going that way
what the hell
oh my god oh oh oh oh
no no no no no
ah wow it was here it was here the whole
time it was in here with me
my lungs are so efficient okay
uh my house has to be does that a shiny
stone i really don't have time for the
shiny stone oh there's a couple
great oh they're right by my no this is
my house
where is this where am i oh no where am
i
shiny stone oh god but where am i i
don't know where i am
oh i'm too far south okay but there's
shiny stones here i can go get those
once i drop off the stuff that'll be the
things that i get
this must be the shrine right yeah i
gotta come back here for those
oh [ __ ] no no no no no no
no no no no you missed me oh my god oh
my god
oh my god oh my god no i'm not
okay
okay ah [ __ ] oh my god
no no ah no
god damn it
what happens what happens when i die do
i
oh freak my stuff god damn it i was so
close to home
you son god [ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it
is my stuff still there what oh my god
oh you no it is oh it is it is still
there
oh it is still there okay well all is
not lost
okay that's fine okay i don't know where
the dog went and i don't care
god damn it's because i uh i can't
wait it's our way to repair this
repair lantern what do you mean it can't
be repaired
will i be able to refill it
whatever it's okay i probably didn't
need to have it on me the entire time
because the rain stopped but i didn't
notice the rain stopped because i was a
little bit busy dealing with all the
hell
okay the pills also didn't heal me up at
all i need bandages let's make a heavy
bandage
and i'll only use this when i absolutely
have to but i'll use the pill otherwise
all right i gotta go
wasted so much time doing that okay
there's shiny stones here me like shiny
so there was shiny stones just around
here somewhere
i saw them oh you know
oh they only show up if i have a light
probably
right they probably glimmer in the light
or not yes they do okay they glimmer in
the light
otherwise you have to be like right on
top of them i need to get those because
they're worth like 120.
you gonna blow up on me i'm not gonna
risk it
search those there's another stone down
here somewhere
there it is okay good okay i gotta get
back because i got a lot of building to
do for my defenses
the day does not last long enough the
day does not last
long enough i don't need to barricade
this one but it feels good to do
uh and then i'll re-barricade this but
i'm also
going to do a little special surprise
given that i have this scrap metal okay
oh god i oh i forgot to turn on the oh i
forgot to turn on the generator
i'm an idiot i'm an idiot i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot i'm an idiot i'm an idiot i
am an idiot i am an idiot i am an
idiot idiot idiot is what i am it is
what i am it is what i am
i am why i am an idiot i am an idiot is
that my stuff is that the backpack full
of my stuff from the other base is that
what that's supposed to be probably
okay i'm gonna put this right
there nice and i'll put another one
right
there all right
ah wow it's my stuff that's good
who where where oh don't do that to me
who and where
i don't know where that's happening
that sounded like something broke open
i'm gonna get off flare just in case
because for some reason if the lights go
out like they did i think maybe a flare
would help oh god hey
how you doing he seems to be having fun
he seems to be having a lot of fun
oh that's new that's new and very
disconcerting
i don't like that i don't like any of
that
well that sounds big
[Music]
oh what the hell is that
what the hell is that but what the hell
what the heck in hell
okay
[Music]
i guess it was nothing i guess the
answer was that it was
nothing i guess the answer was that
there was a whole lot of nothing
hey bud how you doing
hey my good circ hey can i get the
fabric off of you i got some shiny
stones that you are going to
love take these stones my
dude i'll take that fabric off your
hands
i could do another inventory upgrade or
i could do a hot bar upgrade i haven't
really needed to get more hot bar
but the inventory probably does two and
the hot bar probably only does one
i would bet right now i think the
inventory is better
yeah oh yeah um i would love that wire
the mushroom and the rags i guess i'll
take the tape the rope
i mean i've got so much reputation i
probably should just start
getting stuff that i even remotely think
i'm gonna need
okay cook the mushroom almost at another
dose
good great can't wait for that
but let's make this lockpick and i'm
gonna save the lockpick for
things like that door okay we're good to
go i'm gonna leave those bear traps
there
and i'm gonna leave uh now this south oh
my god this door was open that sounded
like something broke open
oh my god oh my god
oh my god all right cool that's great
all right i'm gonna head out what i need
to do is i need to get over to the pig
pen
and i need to or not the pig pen
whatever whatever that person's name is
partrick patrick i need to get over to
patrick's
uh oh boy here we go come on i'll fight
you
oh my god you are an [ __ ]
oh wow you suck i hate you
i should not touch that one i
shouldn't have god damn it i know i
knew it i knew it oh is that gonna kill
me oh my god if that kills me i'm gonna
be
so upset i'm gonna look in here
i wonder if there's a way to just to
bash him open or i gotta kill a dog
apparently
this game really wants me to kill dogs
oh god oh those pills heal quick oh
those pills heal
real quick oh god
you know whatever the person in there is
like what the heck
okay this is why i brought the torch
burn burn
oh well that was just enough okay
you in here hello
gucci hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey don't make me
don't make me oh god you suck
sorry sorry i should have thrown the
meat
oh i forgot about the whole meat thing
god damn it all right fine
toolbox that's good blueprint
to blast off into space i just need xxyz
and uh those things easy peasy
easy peasy let me get a taste of these
mush
okay i think there was a gas in here yep
there's gas in here and i can kind of
combine these
oh that's so yeah i'm not even gonna
bother all right hey
buddy uh killed your dog sorry about
that yeah
i don't know what to tell you it's uh i
didn't want to do it hello
hi how are you patrick
oh oops i didn't hear you come in
the boy's eyes are the boy boy the boy's
eyes are wandering around the room
i found this wiggly metally thing
yesterday
it was laying there in the grass i don't
like grass
it's so slippery and it tickles your
feet rather than grass i would prefer
these metal wigglies all right the metal
antennas on his wirey hats start
vibrating
do you do you have any metal wigglies
uh maybe i have one too it's such a
beautiful photograph
beautiful but i don't see gagarin in it
i have never seen a photo without
gagarin in it before
gagarin was a cosmonaut a man who flew
to the stars
i'll reach the stars too one day maybe
tomorrow for example
i just need to find the screw for the
cover all right
i had one just like this i melted it
into a perfect little ball
shaped like the moon i melt everything
plastic into moons
patrick suddenly becomes excited and
have you seen my vehicle
it's ready well almost ready just a
couple parts missing
i will need to find them and i will have
to repair the casing
the one from the spring that fell off
recently when i was entering the cockpit
i hit my hand
and uh it fell off i thought i was
flying
but it was just that the lights went off
these are the blueprints from my space
rocket almost ready
i broke down the whole tractor to build
it but i'm missing several parts
several very important parts
for example a shiny little mirror and
this rectangular box with wires and
the boy suddenly becomes lost and
thought if only i had more tractors
i would definitely go to space sure
you won't be able to make it home via
this road you should build a rocket
trade ah good
great map of the old woods
oh is that important that seems like it
might be important
i don't really have a ton of stuff to
trade with you using
the idea of using a molotov cocktail
actually scares me so i'm not 100 sure
if i'm gonna do that
i mean gosh that sounds important you
know what sure here
we'll do it even steven's style okay
perfect
well all right all right cool good thank
you
i don't have any wiggly things but i'll
be back for your wires later because
that's actually useful
found church ruins oh
oh old woods hideout okay well that all
right that that actually is helpful
thanks dude
okay all right that's all the time i got
for this right now
i'm gonna end this here and then i'll
pick it up we're gonna make a mad dash
over to the left side then go up and
then all the way back around to the
safety house to get back for the next
night because there's just no
time at all either way thank you
everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you